one of the hottest topics in bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies over the last couple of
years has been regulation there's plenty
of people who say there is no regulatory
clarity in the united states now of
course they're not talking about bitcoin
they're talking about the rest of the
market but in the bitcoin market it is
very clear both the sec the cftc and
many other governing bodies they all
claim that bitcoin is not a security
doesn't get much clearer than that now
when we go we look at the rest of the
market regulators have a choice to make
do they believe these are securities
will they make people comply with
securities law or are they going to
label them as non-securities and allow
people to continue on the path that they
currently are i don't have a crystal
ball i don't know the answer but what i
do know is that there is very clear
regulatory guidance when it comes to
bitcoin that it is not a security the
rest of the market is still uncertain
and so are regulators bitcoin maximus i
don't think you can go that far and say
yes but what i do think is that they've
all reached some level of agreement
bitcoin is not a security so that means
that people who are using it who are
building products who are holding it and
who are investing in it they already
know the rules they know what they can
do and they know what they can't do but
the rest of the market that uncertainty
it gives pause for investors are they
investing in unregulated securities or
are they not time will tell and
regulators eventually will give guidance
but the question is when will that
happen and what will the outcome be i
think that's where a lot of folks are
saying if regulators are going to give
guidance on bitcoin they want the
regulatory clarity they want to
understand what's going on in the rest
of the market i don't have those answers
neither do you only the regulators will
ultimately be the ones that decide that
but what i do know is that the clearest
part of the market the part that
everyone agrees on bitcoin's not a
security and so whether you think that
makes regulators bitcoin maximus or not
doesn't really matter at the end of the
day across governing bodies they all see
bitcoin is not a security and that means
if there's clarity it's the green light
for investors entrepreneurs and
individuals to all start to build around
that asset that's exactly why you're
seeing bitcoin hash rate all-time high
lightning network capacity all-time high
and many other metrics continuing to
grow up into the right bitcoin has
clarity clarity is good clarity
ultimately means you can plan your
business and your investment portfolio
and bitcoin is benefiting from that
regulatory clarity